[Música]
alguna vez notas de algo nadando en tu
campo visual se asemeja a un gusano
pequeño o una burbuja transparente y
cada vez que intentas enfocar los
desaparecen para reaparecer tan pronto
cuando alejas la mirada pero no vayas a
enjuagar de los ojos lo que ves es un
fenómeno común conocido como cuerpos
flotantes el nombre científico de estos
cuerpos es buscar bòlit antes que en
latín significa moscas volantes y fiel a
su nombre pueden ser un poco molestos
pero no se trata ni de gusanos ni de
objetos externos reales en absoluto más
bien existen dentro del globo ocular
las moscas volantes parecen vivas porque
se mueven y cambian de forma pero no lo
están los cuerpos flotantes son objetos
mínimos que proyectan sombras en la
retina el tejido sensible a la luz en la
parte posterior del ojo pueden ser
trozos de tejido glóbulos rojos o
agregados de proteínas y como están
suspendidos en el humor vítreo el
líquido gelatinoso que llena el interior
del ojo flotan a la deriva con el
movimiento de los ojos y parecen rebotar
un poco cuando se detiene
y las moscas volantes apenas se
distinguen la mayor parte del tiempo
llegan a ser más visibles cuanto más
cerca están de la retina al igual que al
acercar más la mano a una mesa con una
lámpara de techo resultará una sombra
definida más claramente y son
particularmente visibles cuando miras
una superficie brillante uniforme como
una pantalla de computadora en blanco la
nieve o un cielo despejado donde la
consistencia del fondo hace que sean más
fáciles de distinguir cuanto más
brillante es la luz más se contrae tu
pupila esto tiene un efecto similar a
cambiar una gran instalación de luz
difusa por una sola bombilla lo que
también hace que la sombra parezca más
nítida hay otro fenómeno visual que se
parece a las moscas voladoras pero que
de hecho no está relacionado
si ves pequeños puntos de luz que
resaltan cuando miras a un cielo azul
brillante has experimentado lo que se
conoce como fenómeno en top tico del
campo azul en cierto modo esto es lo
contrario a ver objetos flotantes aquí
no ves sombras sino pequeños puntos
brillantes en movimiento dejando luz en
tu retina los puntos brillantes los
causan los glóbulos blancos moviéndose a
través de los capilares frente a la
superficie de la retina
estos leucocitos pueden ser tan grandes
que pueden casi llenaron capilar
formando un espacio de plasma que se
abre ante ellos
como el espacio los glóbulos blancos es
más transparente a la luz azul que los
glóbulos rojos que normalmente están
presentes en los capilares vemos un
punto en movimiento de luz donde esto
sucede siguiendo los caminos de tus
capilares y moviéndose al ritmo de tu
pulso en condiciones ideales de
visualización incluso puedes ver lo que
parece ser una cola oscura siguiendo el
punto estos son los glóbulos rojos que
se han agrupado detrás de los leucocitos
algunos museos de ciencia tienen una
exposición con una pantalla de luz azul
que permite ver este fenómeno del campo
azul más claramente que lo normal
aunque los ojos de todos experimentan
este tipo de efectos el número y el tipo
varían mucho en el caso de las moscas
volantes a menudo pasan desapercibidas
porque el cerebro aprende a ignorarlas
sin embargo si son muy numerosas o son
grandes objetos flotantes que
interfieren con la visión pueden ser
signo de una afección más grave que
requiere tratamiento médico inmediato
pero la mayoría de las veces los
fenómenos en top ticos como las moscas
volantes o el fenómeno en tópico del
campo azul son solo un recordatorio de
que lo que creemos ver depende tanto de
nuestra biología y mente como del mundo
externo
y ya que hacemos preguntas importantes
porque hay gente zurda descúbrelo en
este vídeo y asegúrate de suscribirte
para tener siempre la oportunidad de
aprender algo nuevo
ah